[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos si echamos un vistazo al
mapa del mundo y lo analizamos con
detalle nos daremos cuenta de que hay
fronteras muy pero que muy particulares
la de España con Marruecos a través de
las ciudades de ceuta y melilla por
ejemplo es una que suele Llamar mucho la
atención la de Israel con gaza Isis
Jordania también es una de las más
particulares que os voy a contar pero os
alguna pregunta conocéis alguna isla con
alguna frontera un tanto extraña
conocéis el caso de alguna Isla partida
por la mitad en la que las dos Mitades
digamos por ser educados no se soporten
mucho Pues sí esas Islas y esas
fronteras existen quizás muchos estéis
pensando en la frontera que separ a
bruney de Indonesia o en la que parte la
isla de chipre en 2 o quizás también en
Irlanda sin embargo en esta ocasión no
vamos a viajar hasta el sudeste asiático
y tampoco nos vamos a quedar en la vieja
Europa hoy encontraremos a nuestros
protagonistas en pleno mar Caribe porque
Sí en el Caribe hay otra Isla que
también acoge a dos países sabríais
decirme cuál 3 2 1 premio efectivamente
hablamos de la isla de la
[Música]
española y aquí queridos amigos es donde
nos encontramos a la República
Dominicana y a la República de Haití dos
países muy diferentes entre sí tanto por
su cultura como por su desarrollo
económico y social de hecho si recordáis
el vídeo que en visual politic hicimos
sobre Haití hace No mucho tiempo sabréis
perfectamente que esta isla podría ser
el tablero perfecto para el juego hombre
rico hombre pobre hablamos de dos países
que además comparten una turbia historia
de antiguas luchas fronterizas algo que
parecía ya superado sin embargo en los
dos últimos años las tensiones
fronterizas han resurgido el auge de las
pandillas haitianas ha endurecido la
política fronteriza y migratoria de la
República Dominicana Claro que más allá
de las pandillas hay una poderosa razón
que ha terminado por multiplicar toda
esta tensión estamos hablando una vez
más de los recursos naturales
especialmente en este caso de uno muy
particular ular el agua queridos amigos
amigas Cómo llegó a establecerse esta
típica y controvertida frontera Qué está
haciendo la República Dominicana para
intentar frenar el auge de las pandillas
haitianas Por qué decimos que los dos
países de la española están enfrentados
por el agua pues hoy vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas pero antes antes
tenemos que empezar la historia por el
[Música]
principio un golpe tras
otro si hay algo que puede unir tanto a
la República Dominicana como a la
República haitiana es su pasado como
colonias de dos imperios europeos el
español y el francés concretamente Haití
logró independizarse de Francia en 1804
y la República Dominicana lo hizo de
España en 1821 a partir de entonces
lejos de darse la mano comenzó Un siglo
de incesantes luchas entre ambos países
y sobre todo por una razón los
constantes intentos de Invasión
haitianos parece que no les bastaba con
construir un nuevo
país tan solo un año después de
conseguir su independencia la República
Dominicana fue invadida por el líder
haitiano jeanpierre Boyer que dominaría
toda la española desde 1822 hasta
1844 Boyer pronto se ganó el odio de Los
dominicanos con medidas como la
expulsión de profesores del país la
expropiación de tierras a la iglesia o
la obligación a pagar parte de la deuda
que Haití había contraído con Francia
años atrás por eso en
1844 la República Dominicana liderada
por Juan Pablo Duarte y Pedro monana
entre otros consiguió independizarse de
nuevo Solo que esta vez lo hizo de su
vecina Haití no obstante los ataques de
Haití No cesaron por ejemplo en
1855 el emperador haitiano faustin I
envió 30.000 soldados a la República
Dominicana con la intención de volver a
conquistarla pero esa vez no tuvo éxito
desde entonces Haití no volvió a lanzar
ataques a gran escala para tomar
dominicana pero con el fracaso de todas
las negociaciones y mediaciones la
nación francófona sí continúa haciendo
pequeñas incursiones en territorio
dominicano Pero llegó 1929 y ese año
trajo consigo finalmente un tratado de
paz que reconocía las fronteras de ambos
países de
1856 la República Dominicana tuvo
entonces que renunciar a una comarca
fronteriza que había sido ocupada por
Haití después de 1856 pero aparte de eso
el acuerdo fue bien recibido por los
gobiernos de ambos países Claro que por
supuesto la historia no terminó
aquí
el acuerdo estuvo a punto de romperse
por un Terrible y despreciable suceso la
masacre del río da jabón en 1937 Y es
que veréis en 1930 llegó al poder en la
República Dominicana este hombre que
veis en pantalla Rafael leónidas
Trujillo Un teniente coronel y jefe del
Estado Mayor que dio con éxito un golpe
que lo encumbró en el poder con Trujillo
la política hacia los haitianos se
endureció hasta niveles podéis creerme
completamente aterradores el
resentimiento histórico por las
constantes invasiones haitianas y sobre
todo una ideología abiert ente racista
hicieron que Trujillo ordenara la
limpieza étnica de los haitianos en
Dominicana sí habéis escuchado bien
entre el 2 y el 8 de octubre de 1937 el
ejército dominicano acabó con la vida de
entre 9000 y 20,000 haitianos fue una
auténtica y atroz masacre sin embargo el
acuerdo se mantuvo en pie y al final
tanto El dictador Trujillo como el
haitiano elir Scott pusieron fin
definitivamente a las disputas
fronterizas en 1942 desde entonces la
frontera quedó libre de batallas Y tanto
haitianos como dominicanos han podido
pasar de un lado al otro con nativa
facilidad no obstante como os decía
antes desde 2021 la frontera ha vuelto a
ponerse Al rojo vivo y todo por una
nueva amenaza capaz de romper todo las
pandillas haitianas
atentos el profundo caos
haitiano creo que todos sabemos que
América Latina está viviendo una oleada
de violencia que está haciendo que
países que parecían razonablemente
seguros hace tan solo 5 años como
Ecuador Chile o Costa Rica estén ahora
registrando alarmantes datos de
criminalidad no obstante pese a lo
preocupante de la situación de estos
países Nada se compara a lo que está
sucediendo en Haití Eso sí ya os
contamos aquí en visual politic como el
fenómeno de las bandas y las milicias en
Haití No es algo precisamente nuevo de
hecho las podemos rastrear hasta los
años 50 con los llamados tonton makut
durante la dictadura de los duvalier
normalmente estas bandas han estado al
servicio de políticos y empresarios que
han buscado tanto protección como
mayores cotas de poder sin embargo en
2021 nos encontramos con con una noticia
que cambiaría el panorama haitiano de
forma drástica fijaos el presidente
haitiano jovenel mís asesinado en su
domicilio por hombres armados no
identificados efectivamente mis queridos
amigos en julio de 2021 unos mercenarios
en su mayoría colombianos asesinaron al
entonces presidente mois en ese momento
este hombre que veis en pantalla Ariel
Henry tomó entonces la presidencia del
país de forma temporal pero a pesar de
ello las bandas notaron que el asesinato
de mois había dejado un tremendo vacío
de poder un vacío que por supuesto no No
tardaron en llenar actualmente este país
cuenta ya con cerca de 200 bandas de las
cuales 100 tienen presencia en la
capital haitiana Puerto Príncipe que se
ha convertido en una auténtica jungla de
pandillas depredadoras de hecho para
muchos la capital ya ha caído por
completo en manos de estas
pandillas bandas como el maos 400
considerada la más extensa de todo el
país o el g9 la coalición de bandas más
poderosa de todo Haití ya controlan las
costas de Puerto Príncipe que es donde
se encuentran precisamente las
terminales portuarias más importantes
para el comercio del país algo que como
os podéis imaginar les otorga un enorme
poder pero para que os hagáis una idea
del poder que han acumulado tenéis que
saber que el g9 llegó a tomar la
terminal bar rux que es la principal
terminal petrolífera de todo el país
Haití quedó entonces desabastecida de
combustible y la Policía Nacional tuvo
que redoblar sus esfuerzos para poder
recuperarla queridos amigos la situación
de violencia en el país caribeño ha
llegado a tal nivel que incluso el
propio presidente interino Ariel Henry
ha pedido una intervención militar
internacional de locos Pero vale Seguro
seguro que muchos os estaréis haciendo
haciendo una pregunta pero Enrique En
qué afecta todo esto a la República
Dominicana pues veréis lo cierto Es que
dominicana juega aquí un papel crucial
por una simple razón es uno de los ejes
principales del tráfico de narcóticos y
de armas del que se benefician las
bandas
haitianas de acuerdo con la oficina de
las Naciones Unidas contra la droga y el
delito la República Dominicana es uno de
los principales puntos de acceso para
las armas que llegan desde Florida y que
se dirigen a las pandillas haitianas de
hecho para que os hagáis una idea en los
primeros 6 meses de 2022 y tan solo en
el puerto de aina en Santo Domingo oeste
se confiscaron 112,000 unidades de armas
y munición procedentes de Estados Unidos
y no solo eso la República Dominicana
también juega un papel fundamental en el
tráfico de drogas un negocio fundamental
para las pandillas haitianas en otras
palabras que la República Dominicana se
ha convertido en una especie de Mercado
del crimen para las pandillas haitianas
un mercado tanto tanto de entrada como
de salida porque hablamos de una isla
que se ha convertido en un punto de
distribución importantísimo para el
envío de narcóticos tanto a Europa
occidental como a los Estados
Unidos amigos esta caótica situación en
it ha llevado al gobierno dominicano a
endurecer las medidas de entrada al país
desde el otro lado de la isla con el
temor de que las pandillas haitianas
puedan extender su actividad a
dominicana el presidente de este país no
ha dudado en llevar a cabo una campaña
de deportación masiva una campaña que no
ha hecho distinción ni por edad ni por
sexo de esta forma por ejemplo en 2022
llegó a deportar a 171,000 personas un
102 Por más que en 2021 y ojo porque en
2023 se espera que esta cifra alcance
los 250,000 deportaciones Eso sí por
ahora y pese a todo las fronteras se
habían mantenido relativamente abiertas
especialmente para poder facilitar el
comercio entre ambos países sin embargo
algunos acontecimientos recientes están
cambiando esta realidad las tensiones en
la frontera han vuelto tras décadas de
relativa estabilidad y amigos avidan
está demostrando que no se toma en broma
la situación
fijaos el Trump
dominicano recordáis el revuelo mundial
que hubo cuando Donald Trump dijo que
quería construir un muro con México esta
propuesta fue una idea que marcó su
campaña y sobre la que los medios
internacionales pues no pararon de
hablar bien pues sabéis Quién ha
anunciado también la construcción de un
nuevo muro y encima está cumpliendo su
promesa iamente el propio Luis abinader
controvertido muro se parará próspera
República Dominicana y empobrecido Haití
una vez finalizado Este muro fronterizo
una impresionante obra de 4 m de altura
construida con hormigón y acero abarcará
unos 164 km y dividirá a República
Dominicana de su vecina Haití el
presidente abinader ha argumentado que
uno de los principales objetivos de Este
muro es mantener a posibles pandilleros
y criminales haitianos fuera de la
República Dominicana sin embargo otra de
las razones es controlar mejor los
flujos migratorios Y es que Haití es un
caos económico y social sumido en
profundos niveles de violencia Así que
como os podéis imaginar en estos últimos
años cientos de miles de haitianos han
entrado en Dominicana lo que a su vez ha
creado por ejemplo una fuerte tensión en
la atención hospitalaria y no solo eso
sino que con toda esta nueva mano de
obra disponible los salarios dominicanos
también han caído tened en cuenta que
los haitianos ofrecen su mano de obra a
un menor precio y eso explica por qué
gran parte de la población dominicana ha
recibido con los brazos abiertos esta
medida Eso sí tampoco faltan los
críticos muchos dicen que el muro No
servirá para nada y que la corrupción de
los soldados dominicanos fronterizos
dejará pasar haitianos a cambio de
sobornos al mismo tiempo otros temen que
el muro entorpezca la entrada de
trabajadores haitianos que resultan
cruciales para la economía dominicana
pensad por ejemplo que el 80% de la mano
de obra del sector agropecuario de la
República Dominicana es haitiana y no
obstante esto no tendría que ser
demasiado preocupante porque al fin y al
cabo no significa que los haitianos no
vayan a poder entrar a su país vecino
solo significa que habrá un control más
estricto para el acceso o lo que es lo
mismo que no tiene por qué afectar
necesariamente a los trabajadores
haitianos sin embargo en septiembre de
este año 2023 nos encontramos con otra
noticia Que sí que resultó un verdadero
shock y que dejaba muy claro que la
situación fronteriza entre ambos países
volvía a ponerse Al rojo vivo República
Dominicana anuncia que cerrará su
frontera con Haití por una disputa de
agua la medida ocurre en medio de un
conflicto por el acceso a un río
compartido por ambos países tal y como
habéis visto Luis abinader ordenó cerrar
la frontera con Haití por una disputa
por por el agua del río dajabón También
conocido como el río masacre un río que
nace y muere en República Dominicana y
que durante una parte de su recorrido
determina la frontera entre ambos países
pero sin adentrarse realmente en
territorio haitiano Pues bien pese a
ello en 2018 Haití comenzó a construir
un sistema de riego con el agua de este
río para los cultivos de la llanura de
marib barush la construcción fue
suspendida en 2021 pero los agricultores
de la zona decidieron retomar ellos
mismos la construcción en agosto de este
año y es que al fin y al cabo la
construcción ya estaba completada en
casi un 60 por. Así que cuando los
agricultores haitianos retomaron la
construcción abinader enfureció insisto
el río no llega a adentrarse en
territorio haitiano más que unos 2 km
Así que Los dominicanos consideran
cualquier desviación de su caudal como
un robo Así que ante esto el presidente
dominicano exigió que se parara la
construcción ya que decía que afectaría
a más de 14000 hectáreas de terreno
cultivable dominicano y a la laguna
saladilla uno de los pocos humedales del
país al final abinader decidió suspender
la emisión de visados a los haitianos y
finalmente cerrar por completo la
frontera con Haití ante esta situación
que traspasa los límites del país vecino
llegando a afectar de forma directa
nuestros intereses y legítimos derechos
hemos entendido la necesidad de dar una
respuesta contundente en legítima
defensa contra los grupos incontrolables
que no obedecen al orden constitucional
haitiano no obstante el cierre
fronterizo no solo ha afectado a los
haitianos sino también a los miles de
dominicanos que dependen del comercio
con Haití por ejemplo en dajabón un
pueblo dominicano de la frontera los
ciudadanos viven en gran medida de este
comercio y cuando las fronteras Se
cerraron los estragos económicos se
notaron muy muy pronto hay que tener en
cuenta que según el alcalde del pueblo
Santiago riverón Todas las semanas se
comercia el equivalente a 4 millones de
dólares en el mercado binacional de
dajabón y como en este municipio Pues
también ocurre lo mismo en muchos otros
pasos fronterizos como Elías Peña o
pedernales por eso a mitad del pasado
mes de octubre el gobierno dominicano se
vio obligado a reabrir parcialmente
algunos enclaves fronterizos para
reactivar el comercio con el país vecino
Es verdad que sigue habiendo un control
estricto para el acceso de haitianos
Pero esto ya supone estar un paso más
cerca de la vuelta a la
normalidad
Mientras tanto los agricultores y el
gobierno de Haití No han dado su brazo a
torcer defienden su derecho a explotar
el agua del río y es que argumentan que
al fin y al cabo el canal que están
construyendo nace en los 2,5 km de Río
que se encuentran en suelo haitiano y en
cierto modo Es lógico que busquen la
construcción de este canal porque con
una inseguridad alimentaria que afecta
al menos a cinco de sus 11,5 millones de
ciudadanos se estima que el canal podría
aumentar los cultivos de arroz de tal
forma que podría asegurar alimento para
al menos 4 millones de haitianos Claro
que sea como sea es innegable que tomar
unilateralmente agua de este río que
apenas toca Haití parece bastante osado
más aún cuando parece violar los
acuerdos existentes sobre la explotación
del Río el debate está servido Así que
ya lo veis la frontera entre Haití y
República Dominicana vuelve a ser fruto
de enormes tensiones el aumento de la
criminalidad en Haití de la mano de las
pandillas y el conflicto por el agua del
río masacre la ha vuelto a poner en el
punto de mira el presidente abinader ha
actuado con contundencia construyendo un
muro endureciendo las políticas de
entrada al país para los haitianos e
incluso cerrando parcialmente las
fronteras muchos lo han apoyado y otros
lo han tildado de exagerado ventajista y
populista que sabe que este tipo de
medidas son muy populares entre un
electorado llamado a votar en mayo de
2024 Pero qué creéis vosotros pensáis
que son medidas justas o exageradas
diríais que serán capaces de lograr un
acuerdo que reabra las fronteras pues
podéis dejarme vuestras respuestas en
los comentarios como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visual politic sacamos
nuevos vídeos Todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para No perderos ninguno de
los siguientes si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta
[Música]
pronto